[Musique]
de belles couleurs des formes
appétissantes pourtant certains fruits
et légumes ont déjà parcouru la moitié
de la planète avant de se retrouver sur
nos étals pour éviter ce genre de
péripéties le bon sens est revenu à la
mode avec le circuit court car consommer
des produits locaux c'est sain c'est
simple et c'est aussi faire vivre toute
une économie régionale
donc tu meures écoles toutes les bleues
celles qui sont pas bien celles qui sont
abîmés mort en manger par les rongeurs
etc tu m'aimais dans ce sens là sur les
parcelles les potimarrons se ramassent à
la pelle
l'association l'entr'aide berruyères
cultive 6 hectares en maraîchage navets
choux radis et panais sortent de terre
dans la plus pure tradition de
l'agriculture biologique vous rappelez
du calibre que d'hyères parce qu'il
fallait récolter niveau de la taille les
petits voulait laisser s'y sont véreux
s'ils sont trop courts et vous me
laissez d'accord on récolte les gros
vous les mettez dans les caisses grise
ici les ouvriers ont un statut un peu
particulier
ce sont des personnes en insertion
professionnelle s'occuper de la terre
est un métier difficile très compliqué
très difficile avec les aléas
climatiques le chaud le froid la pluie
ou voyez aujourd'hui pour mitiger disons
est donc vain malgré ça les gens soient
là harrach où plantes voit rose sera
donc les activités diverses qui leur
permettent de reprendre surtout
confiance en nous en plus de l'aspect
social les légumes produits fournissent
un circuit local et notamment la
restauration collective
depuis quatre ans la production de
l'entr'aide berruyères fini en partie
dans les assiettes du collège littré de
bourges
un partenariat qui nécessite forcément
quelques ajustements il faut qu'ils tout
un système qui se met en place il ya le
producteur il faut qu'ils aient la
volonté travaillais déjà avec les
cuisines ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point qui est tout aussi
important faut que le cuisinier veuille
bien travaillé avec le producteur qu'il
faut aussi que le gestionnaire qui gère
le côté financier des repas vais bien
aussi prendre des produits locaux et bio
pour inscrire en ce qui me concerne les
cuisiniers doivent comprendre nos
problématiques dans la production dans
l'approvisionnement dans l'art activités
consciemment tout je voudrais être
livrés souvent le lundi matin à 8 heures
sauf que nous comment je peux de journée
le lundi matin à 8 heures donc on peut
pas les livres à ce moment là c'est
toute la problématique qui peut y avoir
à 6 heures du matin pourtant à bourges
l'équipe de cuisine du collège littré a
déjà commencé son service préparation
des plats des menus et évaluation des
quantités denis le chef cuisinier
alterne la matinée entre les couteaux et
le clavier d'ordinateur
il s'appuie aussi et surtout sur la
plateforme en ligne agréé locales 18
pour passer ses commandes
ça fait quatre ans qu'elle existe cette
plate forme donc intégré locales 18 ces
départements qui l'a mise à disposition
donc elle est gratuite et pour
l'acheteur et pour les pour les
fournisseurs il suffit simplement de
s'inscrire
alors ce qui est bien une fois que vous
êtes inscrit six mois je recherche des
pommes de terre je fais un appel
d'offres et
les fournisseurs qui sont inscrits
recevoir un petit sms
hamel et y répondent s'ils ont la
marchandise au nécessaire
ici les produits locaux composent 40%
des menus de cette cantine scolaire une
volonté du cuisinier mais aussi de son
équipe
aujourd'hui on fait un petit fondant aux
noix que je testais avant à la maison on
teste les recettes avant et puis si ça
convient à tout le monde si ça convient
à l'équipe de cuisine on met en pratique
après ce normalement ça devrait convenir
aux élèves le vendredi des recettes
maison qui doivent aussi composer avec
de nombreuses contraintes
un budget de 2 euros par personne et la
loi égalité alimentaire qui impose 50 %
de produits labellisés 20% de bio et un
repas végétarien par semaine dans la
restauration collective il déjà nous on
travaille toujours sur un plan
alimentaire c'est un jour consécutif
on a des obligations m 10 10 fois des
légumes
minimum et puis des produits gras le
moins possible sinon ensuite ont
travaillé travaillé en local c'est une
petite gymnastique simplement sur le
maraîchage ses sept plus compliqué
bonjour bonjour denis l' agence bio
centre fait la promotion du bio et des
produits locaux dans les cantines
scolaires
elle propose des formations aux chefs
cuisiniers du département pour adapter
les menus chacun est dans sa cuisine
dans des endroits qui sont complètement
éclaté aux quatre coins du train du
territoire et ils se rencontrent pas ils
restent dans leur cuisine si on veut
avoir des échanges de pratiques city tel
chef a mis en place une un plat
végétarien qui fonctionne auprès de ses
élèves ce qui est important c'est qu'ils
puissent en parler à l'ensemble de ses
collègues est comme ça les collègues
vont pouvoir s'approprier ces recettes
et la mettre en place dans leur propre
établissement
donc ce réseau cette notion de réseau
des changes ne pas se trouver isolées de
pouvoir avoir des formations en commun
ça c'est primordial dans les assiettes
des plats cuisinés sur place et des
produits du terroir
un délice pour les élèves gourmets
voici les entrées sont très bonnes mais
les plats principaux aussi mais j'aime
vraiment les entrées moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on jette moins de
nourriture et c'est vrai qu'on finit
plus facilement nos assiettes
ce que bah c'est vrai que c'est ouais
c'est bon
quand consommer local évite le
gaspillage alimentaire
dans le loir et cher claude gowland ou
est un champion du zéro déchet il lève
une centaine de brebis à mavs et propose
sa viande bio en vente directe depuis
dix ans mais sans ses voisins impossible
pour claude de valoriser ces déchets
ce choix vient de chez mon voisin à yvon
qui était la commune voisine à 5 km et
donc c'est un mélange de graminées et de
luzerne un aliment qui composent le menu
quotidien de ces jeunes bruni elle aussi
bénéficient du circuit court au niveau
du territoire il ya un certain nombre
d'exploitations qui sont passés en bio
aussi depuis vingtaine d'années et donc
on est en lien très proche
et puis on échange du matériel on
échange des matières premières et puis
aussi des conseils d je veux dire des
expériences et sur l'expérience et c'est
aussi très intéressant et claude c'est
son compost qu'il valorise donc on pense
qu'on obtient à partir du troupeau c'est
les pailles de la ferme plus les
déjections des animaux qui forment un
compost c'est à peu près 200 à 300
tonnes par an qu'on obtient sur un
élevage comme celui là et donc ça permet
de fertiliser les terres
il est entreposé là puis transportés
dans les parcelles est épandu à la belle
saison
le compost de claude finit là au pied
des noyers d'alain yvon son voisin
normalement cette année ça devrait être
la première récolte on a eu des années
un peu difficile des années sèches
du coup ça sera peut-être que l'année
prochaine est fausse moi je suis
convaincu que on a aussi besoin de deux
matières animales dans nos sols dans
dire qu'on a on a dû la flore de la
faune au sol on a des micro organismes
etc
mais il ya des choses qui sont que qui
sont pas j'allais dire naturellement
dans le sol qui se développe
moins vite et donc en fait ces bactéries
ces micro-organismes on les a portés le
compost de claude nourrit les soldes
alain alain fait pousser le foin pour
claude leurs activités sont
complémentaires
aller chercher des matières premières
chez son voisin ça limite le transport
mais c'est aussi l'occasion de rompre l
isolement dans les campagnes l'invention
du siècle pour les paysans s'attelle
téléphone portable un milieu agricole ou
faut pas se cacher il ya c'est quand
même difficile au quotidien
bon il ya un film qui est sorti a pas
très longtemps au nom de la terre les
6,6 dans la grille tu sais quand même
quelque chose qui est important les
dépressions certainement aussi qu'on
doive certainement moins donc c'est vrai
que fait de d'échangé de partage et de
faire partie d'un réseau de passer ça
soutien psychologique ça c'est certain
c'est ça
[Musique]
avec ceci
au marché de theillay le lundi matin
la camionnette de julie fait désormais
partie du paysage
[Musique]
on est contents de trouver anticipé un
petit poireau du coin bon après il ya
des choses des légumes qui sont un peu
plus loin mais je privilégie ce qui
effraie la proximité on regarde la
région parisienne on essaye un peu de de
revenir à des circuits plus courts du
produit plus simple il faut manger local
et essayer d'avoir des bons produits
c'est sûr je pense que là parce que
l'alimentation c'est quand même le
facteur numéro un santé julie propose
des produits 100% locaux et le plus
souvent en bio ou en agriculture
raisonnée
elle rend accessible aux habitants des
villages ruraux un panel de produits de
la région et aux framboises avoue aussi
au revoir l'idée c'est d'avoir des
produits on va dire de tous les jours
j'ai pas envie d'être simuler une
épicerie fine
donc même s'il ya quelques petits
produits qui peuvent être un petit peu
plus haut de gamme mais ces voix là
c'est vraiment se nourrir au quotidien
avec les produits locaux
j'ai trois critères de sélection on va
dire plus précis le premier c'est la
qualité du produit faut que le produit
me plaisent à moi
le deuxième critère c'est la
convivialité que je peux avoir avec les
producteur donc les changes qu'on peut
avoir
et c est le troisième point c'est leurs
pratiques environnementales et votre
miel
voilà bah bonne dégustation alors vous
redire et c'est ça vous va dans la
semaine je fais trois commandes de
légumes donc sur deux maraîchers donc
faut toujours penser à ce qu'on fait moi
il faut que ce soit aussi j'essaie
d'optimiser en disant je vais passer par
là donc ça va être tel jour où je vais y
aller faut qu'ils puissent aussi donc
c'est une vraie logistique
ces deux petits essais un tiers à peu
près de mon temps d'ailleurs une fois le
marché terminé
l'épicière va chercher les fruits et
légumes pour la semaine suivante
direction le verger des perrin à
châtillon sur cher
[Musique]
vous
christine bah oui et toi je te rends tu
as quasi vide
ok je vais chercher ma commande philippe
et christine perrin ont repris la ferme
familiale pour presque tous modifiés
dans l'organisation et la production ils
vendent depuis 20 ans l'intégralité de
leurs pommes directement aux
particuliers
le couple a soutenu julie dans son
projet d'épicerie ambulante dès le début
n'est pas une relation de fournisseur à
client n'a pas de cette relation là on
va plus sur une relation de partenariat
si on a besoin d'eux de quelque chose de
particulier c'est facile a demandé et
voilà c'est des gens qui sont
disponibles pour plein de choses
oui c'est bien moi pas trop grosse à
maintenant les gens ils préfèrent en
petit parce que votre mêlée coupe en
deux donc c'est bien moi ça me va c'est
d'accord super très bien s'est plaint
monsieur s'est plaint encore de rien
encore de la journée de julie n'est pas
terminée elle repart sur les routes de
sologne pour aller se fournir en légumes
cette fois ci à la ferme sainte marthe
c'est lui et lisandro ça va ça va bien
autant impeccable j'ai cherché mes
légumes
tu as préparé la ferme sainte marthe est
une institution en loir et cher elle
fait partie des exploitations pionnière
dans la bio depuis les années 60
ici on produit des légumes en utilisant
des méthodes naturelles
c'est vraiment un changement des
mentalités qu'il faudra pour tunis et de
mieux se comporter vis-à-vis de la
nature et que ça donc il faut vraiment
[Musique]
éduqué dans entre guillemets je n'ai pas
la prétention mais quand même on n'est
pas sachant donc on apprend peu joué
dans la vie achetez directement aux
producteurs
manger local toutes ces initiatives en
plus d'être bonne pour notre planète
stimule le tissu économique local
cela permet aussi de fixer les emplois
sur notre territoire avec les circuits
courts les comportements des
consommateurs se modifie et transforme
profondément notre société